Time has become difficult with natural disasters, leading political agitation and uncertainty
Regarding the future.
While most memes revolve around the horrors of the times in which we live, you may be surprised
To see your life now compared to what it would have been to be in the past.
In fact, most of history includes the subordination of man to malnutrition and hunger.
In ancient Egypt, severe drought could cause death to 5 to 10% of the population.
Today's crops are not ideal, of course, with 11% of the population of France suffering from food insecurity
Which means that their nutrition is limited by the social and economic situation, and they eat small amounts of nutritious foods
With too much carbohydrate and salt, but compare this with years
1692-1694 when literally 15% of the French population died because of the high price of food only.
While millions today suffer from malnutrition, technological development, and government agencies
NGOs help to ensure a majority
In fact, for the first time in human history, overweight people are more malnourished.
When the human race began to live in cities, there was a tremendous rise in disease.
During the 1330 years there was a terrible outbreak of what they thought were demons, foul air or angry gods
Killed 75 to 200 million people.
We are aware that flea was the dwelling place of Yarsine plague, which is historically known
Black Plague.
But people at that time did not realize what was killing them.
In 1520 a small Spanish fleet bound for Mexico was carrying a person
Has an early case of root disease.
The disease kills within two months one-third of Mexico's population
In the years that followed, several infectious diseases spread in Mexico
Bringing the population down from 22 million to 2 million in a span of 60 years.
Deaths from diseases continued unabated and no one knew how to cure them.
The medication then included praying, taking cool showers and rubbing black beetles on the sores.
Until recently, in 1981, the Spanish flu spread internationally and within a few months
Infection has spread to one-third of the world's population, with 3 to 5% dying
Today, our concern about flu is associated with acupuncture needles.
Modern medicine saves millions of lives.
The vaccine for smallpox eradicated the disease entirely from our planet.
When diseases such as severe acute pneumonia or Ebola occur and the world wakes up to a severe emergency for public health
The number of deaths is much lower thanks to international organizations, new technology and continuous medical progress.
When Europe colonized America, there were as many as 100 million people dead
But the pre-colonial population is not well documented, so some estimates go up to millions more.
85 million people died during World War II and in ancient agricultural societies
Human violence caused 15% of the total number of deaths.
Today human violence causes 1% of the total number of deaths.
In 2012, 120,000 people lost their lives in wars, while 1.5 million died of diabetes.
For the first time in human history, most people do not assume war when looking at the receptor
When we meditate this year, while there are still famine diseases, wars and inequality,
We find that it is radically better than most human history.
But we must remain critical of our government, challenge companies and rethink
In how human society is structured in order to sustain progress
, Recognizes the successful human effort in medical research, economic reforms and peace initiatives
And government support to reduce hunger, epidemics and violence will be found
Hope for the future.
Hope is a value concept that needs to be emphasized while looking for a path of satisfaction in a world
It may sometimes seem overwhelmingly bad.
If you want some fun explore the latest shirt we made
"The rotation of the earth makes my day", which we will launch in the next two weeks
Only in asapscience.com/merch
We really appreciate your support during all these years and we would not appreciate doing this video without you!